harry a huge troll is on the rampage
he's cornered hermione and the girls
toilets
people of the internet retro racking
tour here
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we are back with another episode of
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
or harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
we have just gotten out of the dungeons
i'm not sure why we just randomly lost
the music
but we just got out of the dungeons with
snape and
it now is halloween and ron has just ran
up to inform us that
hermione has went missing we all know
what's coming next
but let's go ahead and experience it
anyway let's dive right back in
try to rescue her straight away she's
stranded in the girls bathroom
so we don't get to go to the halloween
feast i'm kind of worried that we only
have
half of our health bar right now instead
of being able to get full health because
when we were in the dungeons there were
just there were chocolate frogs
everywhere and then all of a sudden the
bloody baron hit us like two or three
times and
we're below half health now so kind of
in trouble hopefully there's a spot on
the way
escape the troll oh my goodness this is
it guys this is it
troll troll in the dungeon
i don't think they know yet i don't
think they know yet dude
there he is oh my goodness
oh my goodness we got birdie bop beans
here the controls
are super bizarre and weird and strange
right now
but i'm going with it we're gonna make
it happen we've got to get away from
this troll
slightly different than it happened in
the books and movies
but you know what we're just gonna roll
with it we gotta get away from him and
then
i assume at some point we're gonna use
wingardium leviosa here
jump harry jean parry
all right putting a little bit of
distance between us and him
oh oh
oh man he can jump quite a long way are
you kidding me
whoa that was a big jump
oh my goodness that was a huge jump well
done harry
a nice generous save point right there
along the way
oh here we go here we go wait did we did
we just
lead him to the girls bathroom
we did oh my goodness we did
oh that's i like that
that's hilarious
here we go here we go
[Music]
all right come on let me help you ron
whoa okay wait what am i supposed to be
doing here
oh to keep the junk from hitting us
gotcha dude
oh sorry ron sorry
there we go okay okay
okay oh sorry ron i'm sorry
dude whenever i try and aim it it makes
it worse
i think it's better when i just like
kind of get right here
what why is it not breaking it
there we go i gotta aim a little bit
lower
[Music]
oh my goodness
there we go there we go
oh my goodness ron i'm so sorry bro
oh there we go we drilled the toilet how
about a sink
no we missed the sink
[Music]
there we go oh he's really mad now ron
come on with that with guardian leviosa
spell my friend
come on dude wow
yeah whenever it's whenever it's going
toward ron
it's much harder to hit
see when it's coming toward me it's not
too bad really
kind of just line it up yeah that one
like
i don't know what else to do i have no
idea man
see perfect when it's heading right
toward me
there we go maybe i just need to stand
in front of him
oh we got you now ron we got you dude
now i'm second guessing myself in the
books
remind me you guys it's been so long
since i read sorcerer's stone
do they actually lead the troll into the
bathroom and then they're like oh man
hermione was in there because of course
that's not what happened the movie
but now i feel like i i did i almost
feel like that's what happened in the
book
that they did trap the troll in the
bathroom
either way how the game did it how the
game pulled it off
with you running away from him was
pretty hilarious
run drop
the stick on his head now
there you go there you go ron nicely
done
thanks for saving me is he dead
she sounds so calm being knocked out oh
yeah look look at his ear twitching
you see his ear twitching right there
oh my goodness from their encounter with
the troll harry ron
and hermione yeah strange goings on oh
they're not gonna have the teachers
catch us
with the troll we're just gonna leave it
in there you guys
don't we don't need to tell anybody
it'll be fine
yeah i mean that seems like a good
suspicion here
since harry was busy preparing for the
second quidditch match
against ravenclaw oh second quidditch
match let's go
let's go quidditch i'm your cup
all right we ended the first quidditch
match against slytherin in
record time let's see how we do in
this one here the controls on this are
very strange because it's
all it's all with the keyboard i know i
talk about it every time but it's just
so strange oh not doing good okay
slow it down
stay close to it we gotta build up that
meter
oh there you go there you go harry come
on
[Music]
my health did i not get a good night's
sleep before the quidditch match come on
how are they not going to give me full
health going into the quidditch match
oh in there come on let me grab it let
me grab the stitch
no
[Music]
oh my gosh dude oh our meter our meter's
going down fast
no it didn't no it didn't we're still
we're still hot on the trail of the
snitch lee jordan
but why is the meter going down why is
the meter going
down
i know it helps to oh here we go
[Music]
there we go all right we survived the
match
our health wasn't depleted we managed to
catch the golden snitch
and man this has already been a very
action-packed episode we had the troll
gryffindor versus ravenclaw let's see
what's up next here
oh back to hagrid's okay spent most of
their free time in hagrid's heart
oh yes sorry hagrid you can't keep
norbert
it's cool if they had this in the game
they didn't have this in the movie
i mean they had norbert but very very
brief very brief
harry unwrapped the unexpected christmas
invisibility cloak
let's go it's
[Music]
one of the three deathly hallows we know
now
a very merry christmas to you
harry tried on the cloak oh we're
actually gonna get the scene where they
they take norbert that's awesome said
hermione
you can't stay invisible while you cast
spells okay you
i like that that's kind of a good
balance like
safely bundled up harry set off for the
tallest tower
he hoped that the cloak would conceal
him from filch at his cat
this is i like the idea
that they say
they they don't make it super easy with
the with the cloak like
if you're going to cast a spell you kind
of have to come out from under the cloak
that's that's a good idea
and you know what i almost i think this
would be a great opening to the next
episode so
i think we're going to go ahead and call
it here guys i know this was a bit of a
shorter episode but it was indeed an
action-packed episode if you all enjoyed
this video make sure you give it a
thumbs up
and if you're new to the channel make
sure you subscribe and ring the bell so
you won't miss any of our new
videos guys as always thank you so much
for watching i'll talk to you again soon